Listen, no matter what you do in life, you're
always negotiating.
Whether you're dealing with your boyfriend,
girlfriend, husband, wife, kids, boss, parents,
family, cousins.
It doesn't matter.
You're always negotiating, so the sooner you
become a better negotiator, and learn the
mistakes you're making, the better results
you'll start getting when it comes down to
negotiating.
Today, I'm going to talk to you about the
14 common mistakes people make when it comes
down to negotiating.
Now there's a lot more out there.
I'm just giving you 14 of them.
Number one, letting your emotions get in the
way when you're negotiating.
Let me explain what I mean by this.
It doesn't matter what it is, if a parent
goes to school and is talking to a principal
because their kid did something wrong, the
parent always thinks their kids are perfect,
and they don't make mistakes, because it's
their product.
The same when you're selling a house to somebody
else, you always think your house is worth
more than it really is because it's your house.
You've been living in it for eight years,
nine years.
The market would generally tell you what your
house is worth, what you car is worth, whatever
you're selling.
You got to figure out a way to put yourself
out of the situation and kind of be a consultant
looking in, instead of being somebody that's
involved emotionally in it where you don't
typically end up negotiating the proper way.
You can't just let your emotions get into
... Especially if the other person says, "I
think this thing's only worth $4,000."
You think it's $10,000, you're absolutely
furious.
You may lose a deal there, and you got to
kind of figure out a way what it is.
Number two, misinterpretation of position.
This if very important, because sometimes
you're talking to somebody, and they say something,
and you get upset.
They didn't mean what you thought they meant.
Instead of getting upset, ask two, or three,
or four more questions, probing questions
to ask them what they mean by this.
"Do you mean this?
Do you mean this?"
"That's not at all what I'm saying.
I'm saying this because of this."
"Oh, I didn't even think about that."
"Okay, no problem."
A lot of times, deals don't go through because
there's not enough questions being asked,
because the two parties negotiating misinterpreted
each other.
All right, so you you got to make sure you
got a lot more questions there so this doesn't
happen.
Number three, research, research, research.
Do as much research as you can.
Let me give you a story here.
We had a case where somebody contacted us.
They wanted me to be in this documentary,
and "Oh, this documentary is going to have
a Buddha in it, and Tony Rob ..." All this
stuff.
It sounded so fancy, and we want you to be
an associate producer, and we're standing
there saying, "Wow this is pretty exciting.
This is something that maybe we'll entertain,
want to be a part of," until we found out
that the executive producer that was a part
of it had, had a major, major scandal, New
York Times type of scandal, that he was dealing
with, from a relationship with a younger girl.
All this other stuff.
The moment we found out, we backed down.
We said, "We're not even doing any business
with this."
We almost did.
We almost did because we didn't do research.
One of the things I want to tell you is this
video is sponsored by Fiverr, and one of the
things I love that Fiverr does, Fiverr offers
a service where people will literally research
any topic you want for you.
They'll research any topic for you, so if
you have a topic so say, "Hey, I'm getting
ready to negotiate with this company.
What can you find our about this company,
or what can you find out about the real estate
market today?
What can you find out about Bitcoin today?
What can you find out about such and such
today?"
Somebody will sit there, and they'll research
for you.
Typically you can find out who does a better
job.
I normally recommend choosing three people
if you really want some solid research.
I'd rather pay three different people $50
a pop than use one person, because I can figure
out which one's doing a better research.
Then I'll go use that other person, so if
you've never used Fiverr before, go try the
service out.
You can always go out there right now, have
a relationship with them.
If you use the coupon code PATBET, PATBET,
you will get a 20% discount, so if it's $150,
20%, $30 off, so be sure to go use that service
on researching for yourself on any topic you
want to do.
Number four, going to the source.
I like to go to the source.
I remember a long time ago when I was getting
contracts with insurance companies, and I
was constantly talking to all these VPs, Vice
Presidents.
"Oh yeah, we'll try to get a deal for you.
Oh yeah, we'll try to get a deal for you,"
and all of a sudden I said, "You know what,
I'm going straight to the source."
I found that every insurance company CEOs,
I found that all of these guys are human beings,
like you and I, they have a Linkedin, they
have a contact information.
They know people that have information that
I know, so I reached out to them.
Eventually I got ahold of the CEOs.
Direct phone.
I spoke to them.
I said, "Listen, here's who I am.
Here's what I'm looking for.
I'm looking for a contract.
I just started a company.
I like our company.
When can we get together and talk?"
"Can you come here tomorrow?"
"Yes."
I flew to Chicago, struck up a deal with the
CEO, came back.
We had an insurance company to work with because
I went directly to the source.
Many times you got to go straight to the source.
Number five.
Leverage.
Let me tell you what I mean by leverage.
Leverage is knowing who has the leverage.
I've seen people negotiate with people as
if they have the power, and they don't.
Let me explain.
Let's just way me and and a bank are having
a problem here together.
The bank has given me $50 million for my business,
okay?
The bank is absolutely upset with me.
We want our $50 million.
We've given you $50 million and this is our
$50 million.
If they push me to the edge, I can file bankruptcy.
They'll lose $15 million.
They need to understand leverage here.
They need to make sure I stay in business,
because if I stay in business, I can pay them
back.
That is leverage right there, so you need
to know your position of leverage.
Not just necessarily going in and pounding
your fist on the table and saying, "This is
what I demand from you."
If you don't have proper leverage, it will
work against you.
Number six, not listening.
It's pretty simple.
Sometimes the whole thing about misinterpretation,
the more you listen, you'll start seeing signs,
and you'll start seeing exactly what's important
to them, and you'll start seeing what they're
not willing to negotiate with.
That will help you get to the final decision
sooner.
Number seven, knowing when to walk away, and
when not to walk away.
I will tell you from personal mistakes, I
have sometimes walked away way too early,
and it cost me millions of dollars.
I have sometimes walked away too late, and
it cost me a lot of hours.
Okay?
From experience, you generally make this thing
tighter where you'll be able to save more
money, make more money, and save more time,
and make more time to do other things.
There are times where you're into it, and
you may not like somebody, or you may not
like something that was said, but that doesn't
mean you're not going to do business with
them.
Unpeel it a little bit more, and all of a
sudden, something could happen.
There's sometimes patience is important.
Many time you can tell a deal and say, "Look,
we were just doing a deal," and I told the
guy, "Listen, I want to do this deal, but
I'm not going to do based on these guidelines.
If you have something better, honestly go.
I'm just here waiting.
If you want to do some like this, I'm open."
Then we came back two months later, and we
ended up doing a deal, because we were patient
about it.
You need to know your position where you are
with that.
Number eight.
Too extreme, too soft, too hard.
You push too hard, you're too soft.
If you're too soft, you're showing a weak
position.
Maybe your product's not as good.
If you're too hard, maybe the other person
says, "This person's going to be difficult
to do business with."
You to to kind of figure out a way to be balanced
with them while you're dealing with them.
Number nine.
Understanding the personality.
I was doing a negotiation with this one guy.
He's $100 million guy two weeks ago.
We're on a call.
He interrupts me, three times on a call.
I don't mind it, but he interrupts me three
times.
When he interrupted me three times, I interrupted
him and I said, "Listen, I just hope your
understand this.
I have zero problem if you interrupt me.
Okay?
I hope you also don't have a problem if I
interrupt you."
He said, "I have no problem with that."
Our relationship was so good because we both
understood what level we're comfortable and
in negotiation went well.
There are people that will not even interrupt
you until you're done with your sentence,
and then you got to know they're expecting
the same thing in return.
Sometimes you got to read personalities when
you're negotiating on where they're at.
Some people are more sensitive than others.
When you're dealing with more sensitive people,
if you still want the deal to get done, you
got to be able to read that other human being
better.
Number 10.
Letting people know how you do business.
I told this guy ... Mario reminded me this
yesterday, two days ago.
He says, "Pat, you probably said this line
hundreds of times in meetings."
I'll sit with somebody I'm doing business
with, and I want a long-term relationship
with them.
I'll tell them, I said, "Listen I'm not looking
for a one night stand.
I'm done with one night stands.
I'm looking for marriage.
If you want to marry me, why don't we start
dating, and then from there possible we will
put a ring on each other, and then one day
we'll get married?
I'm looking for a marriage, not a one night
stand.
What are you looking for?"
"I also want a marriage."
"Why don't we start solving around this on
how we can make this relationship last a long
time so you make millions, we make millions.
Are you okay with that?"
"Yes."
Explain to people how you do business with
people.
Number 11.
Caring too much.
This kind of goes a little bit into the emotion
side.
When you caring too much about the deal because
you have a personal ... Many times a deal
may not get done just because you care way
too much about the deal.
12.
Focusing only on the money.
There are a lot of negotiation books out there
that want you to get all the money, and all
this other stuff.
Listen, I've played that card as well, where
it's all about how much of the money I'm going
to get myself.
Then what happens in this case is that person
walks away.
I said this on a call the other day.
I told this guy, I said, "Listen if we do
business, two months later I realize you got
the better end of the deal, you're not going
to get the better version of me, so what do
you want to do?"
He says, "Yeah, you're right Pat.
That kind of does make sense.
Well what can we do for you not to feel that?"
I said, "Well this is my number."
He says, "Well that's kind of fair."
I said, "Well I want to be able to do this."
I said, "Can you give me this other part?
What about if I wanted this?"
I said, "That's no problem to me, but I want
you to make sure that here's what I'm looking
for."
Negotiating just for the money, there are
some freedoms, and some other things you can
negotiate that may be important to you or
to them, that's more important than the money
part, so don't always just leave it on thee
money side.
Number 13, trying to beat the other person.
I had somebody that we had in our lives two
years ago, okay.
Every conversation with her, she had to win.
Literally, it was only about beating you in
the conversations.
I stopped talking.
I'm just sitting there saying, "What do you
want me to talk to you about?
What other conversation do you want the win?
Do you want to win another one?
Keep winning."
There is no point of negotiating with this
person, or even trying to have a relationship
with this person, because it was always about
beating the other person.
It was always about winning the argument,
and there's not a lot that you can do with
that part.
When negotiating with people, you got to know
it can't just be about beating the other person,
it's about I want to keep doing business,
and this person's going to talk to five other
people.
I want them to come back and want to do business
with me.
Number 14.
Not seeking other options.
Every time somebody at the homme office comes
up to me with a deal, "Pat this is going it
cost us $100,000.
This is going to cost us $600,000.
This is going to cost us $50,000."
No matter what deal they will come to me with,
I always ask them one question, "How many
other options do we have?
Do we have three options?"
If it's only one option, no, it's not enough.
I want three.
I always want three options on a house I want
to buy.
Three options for a vacation home I'm looking
at.
Three options for a car I want to buy.
Three options for a technology I want to do.
Three options for a person we want to hire.
Three options for somebody we're bringing
as ... Everything is about three options.
When I have three options, I can say, "Decipher
through the three, and this is the one I want
to go with, not the other two."
You want to have options when you're negotiating.
It gives you leverage.
Last but not least.
I had this on this side here.
Knowing your BATNA which is Best Alternative
To a Negotiated Agreement.
Here's what that means.
It means here the guy offers me $10,000.
I know in the back of my mind, I've got $11,000
somebody else that wants to do it, so my number's
$11,000.
He has to do above $11,000 for me to do business
with him.
In the back of my mind my BATNA is $11,100,
let's just say.
I'll walk in because I've got an $11,000 deal.
I know my conversation with this is not a
big challenge, because if it doesn't happen,
I've got 11K waiting for me.
In anything you're doing, always know your
BATNA.
The more BATNA, the more clear you are with
your BATNA, it gives you leverage when you're
negotiating with whoever you are negotiating
with.
Having said that.
By the way, there are a lot of other things
when it comes up to negotiation with mistakes,
this is just a simple short video for you
to be thinking about on some of the things
you may be doing that you can adjust.
Remember last but not least, Fiverr, PATBET
20% off on any of the services you use with
Fiverr, if you got any questions, thoughts,
comments about this video, comment on the
bottom, and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel yet, click here to subscribe, and
click the alert button to be part of the notifications.
Thank you everybody.
Bye, bye.